bu Halo Herkese merhaba arkadaşlar Yeni
bir dersimize Hoşgeldiniz bugün konumuz
len da unut rahatını yani ülkeler ve
diller hemen alırsak dersimize geçelim
bu dersimizde neler öğreneceğiz önce bir
kalemimi alıyorum
Lena 13 bırakın ülkeler ve diller
Nasyonal it it Milliyet yani kökenimiz
personalpronomen şahıs zamirlerini
öğreneceğiz diverman çıkışın fiilini ve
Komün fiilini öğreneceğiz buradaki tek
dikkat etmemiz gereken Komün fiili
düzenli fiil çıkışın fiili konuşmak
anlamına gelen fiil ise düzensiz bir
fiil ve son olarak da andırı Porsche
telin başkasının tanıtma konusunda
öğreneceğiz hemen dersimize başlayalım
Öncelikle ülkelerimiz de başlayalım Land
ülke
hemen şuraya ekliyorum şu Bu aşağı
sizler için bir köşe hazırladığım bilsem
süper olur köşesi burada tüm
kelimelerimi Das Land ülke ile aynı
şekilde buradan takip edeceğiz dinas
yonit et Milliyet ya da ne demiştik
köken
ton ve diş plağı değil Burada gördüğümüz
Tüm kelimeleri artikelleriyle yani
önündeki tanımlayıcısı ile birlikte
öğrenmemiz gerekiyor Evet ülkelerden
başlayalım ilk olarak
Digiturk ay Türkiye Peki Türkiye'de
hangi dil konuşuluyor Turkish Türkçe
Nasyonal itret diğer Türk'ü dediğimde
ben bir erkekten bahsediyorum diğer
Türk'ü Digiturk'ün dediğimde ise bir
kadından bahsediyorum yani burada
birazcık cinsiyet ayrımı yapıyoruz değer
Türk'e erkek Hatta şuraya şöyle küçücük
ekleyelim ilk olarak bu için kadın
diyoruz iki ülkemiz Deutschland bunu çok
fazla duymuşsunuzdur
Deutschland Almanya
Deutsch Almanca ve yine Nat sonra Lite
dediğimizde yani Milliyet kökenimizi
söylemek istediğimizde de a Deutsche
erkek di Deutsche kadın olarak
ayırıyoruz Aslında her ikisi de Alman
anlamına geliyor ya da diğer Türk'ü
Digiturk'ün Her ikisi de Türk anlamına
geliyor tek ayrım yaptığımız nokta der
Deutsche dediğimizde bir erkekten
bahsediyoruz Alman dil Deutsche
dediğimizde bir kadından bahsediyoruz
frankrijk Fransa Allah şu proces
dediğimizde dil konuşulan bir Fransız
Öziş Evet söylemesi kulağı birazcık
komik gelebilir biraz da zor gelebilir
ama birkaç söylemeden sonra diliniz
hemen alışacak Fransa ve yine der
Frontoza dediğimde bir erkek fransızdan
bahsediyorum Deep Friends ozinn
dediğimde ise bir kadın fransızdan
bahsediyorum Evet ikisi de yine Fransız
anlamına geliyor son ülkemiz şifanin
İspanya konuşulan dil shukra House Şifa
niş Peki yine aynı ayrı mı yapıyoruz
değer çıkan ya erkek İspanyol diş
penyelerin kadın İspanyol Öncelikle önem
vermemiz gereken kelimelerimiz bilsem
süper olur köşemizde ki üç kelimede
Aslan tül kedi Nasyonal it it Milliyet
ya da köken diyoruz ve diş plağı değil
Hemen devam edelim dört ülkemiz daha var
Ruslan Rusya
Rose ruj konuşulan dil Rusça
çar Us iş gördüğünüz gibi o
s harfimiz var ama okuması telaffuz
etmesi gayet kolay Nasyonal it it köken
ise değer rusa erkek Rus bir erkekten
bahsediyorum dirilsin kadın Rus bir
kadından bahsediyorum ama her ikisi de
dediğim gibi bir Rus anlamına geliyor
köken olarak
İtalya'nın İtalya konuşulan dil İtalyan
iş değer italyana erkek İtalyan
dijital Yener'in kadın İtalyan Burada
dikkat etmemiz gereken nokta nasıl ayırt
edeceğiz diye soracak olursanız Eğer der
ve sonundaki Eğer e harflerini
gördüğümde ben bir erkekten bahsediyorum
din ve sonundaki iyi ve ne harflerini
gördüğümde ise iyi ve ne eklerini
gördüğümde ben bir kadından bahsediyorum
buradaki ayrımı bu şekilde yapabiliriz
dişewite İsviçre konuşulan dildir için
ve Fransız iş yani Hem Almanca konuşuyor
hem de Fransızca konuşuyor Diğer şu
baysa erkek Peki İsviçreli diş Vay serin
kadın İsviçre'de ne demiştik başındaki
ve sonundaki eklere bakarak kadın mı
erkek mi olduğunu ayırt edebiliyoruz son
ülkemiz ise Şina Şina Çin
konuşulan dil şenez işine zzish ders ne
yazıyı erkek Çinli diş Nez'in kadın
Çinli Evet hemen bir sonraki konumuza
geldik personalpronomen un yani kişi
zamirleri ya da şahıs zamirleri
diyebiliriz altı tane aynı Türkçe'deki
gibi altı tane şahıs zamiri miz var bu o
Zynga yani tekil olanları 3 adet pulur
al yani çoğul olanları ise
3 adet Ama görünüşte 4 adet gibi
gözüküyor oraya hemen birazdan dönüyorum
Öncelikle tek illerimize bakalım İş
Ben
Duygu sen
Sen şimdi burada üçüncü tekil şahıs ımız
olan eğer ziet üç tane tekil şahıs
görüyoruz şurada L unutmuşuz hemen
ekliyoruz üç tane tekil şahıs görüyoruz
Peki bu 3'teki şahısın anlamları farklı
mı Evet farklı Türkçe'den farklı olarak
mesela Türkçede Biz o derken hem
karşımızdaki bir kadını gösterebiliriz
Hem bir erkeği gösterebiliriz hem de
cansız bir varlığı gösterebiliriz ama
Almancada Er dediğimizde o demiş
oluyoruz ama bir bu ten bahsediyoruz o o
azi dediğimizde yine o demiş oluyoruz
ama bir kadından bahsediyoruz ve Es
dediğimizde ise yine o Ödemiş oluyoruz
ya cansız varlıklardan bahsediyoruz ya
da nötr varlıklardan bahsediyoruz üç
tane tekil şahıs ımızı bu şekilde
kullanıyoruz çoğullara geldiğimizde ise
Via
biz fark ettiyseniz İngilizce çok
benziyor Via ya da We mesela
İngilizce'deki diğer tanımıyla İyi siz
zirai onlar çoğu anlamda peki burada
kiz.ihl
nasıl kullanıyorum Neden iki tane zi var
burada kizi büyük seni olan zi Hatta
şöyle yapıyorum ve Ama siz anlamına
geliyor Evet çoğulda da kullanabiliyorum
ama daha çok Karşımda bir büyüğüm varsa
bir öğretmenin varsa bir iş arkadaşım
varsa ben kibar anlamda onu hitap etmek
için zi kişi zamirine kullanıyorum
mesela
Zirve Fest
My
New L Renault O benim öğretmenim şimdi
cümlenin başındayken Ben tabii ki s
harfini büyük yazacağım ama cümlenin
içinde de benim zik kişi zamiri mi
kullanacak olursam yine s harfini büyük
yazmak zorundayım İlk olarak bunu
buradan ayırt edebiliriz Peki ben buna
bir
isim takalım beraber bir isim koyalım ki
barzee diyelim ki
barzee yani biri çok kibar Olarak hitap
edecek semne yapıyorum kim arz iyi
kullanıyorum şimdi tekil şahıs larımız
dan sonra Evet hemen fiiller konumuza
geçelim ver ben fiiller Şubat haber Ben
westparka veya bir olarak filmlerimizi
ikiye ayırıyoruz şifa ver bunu derken
düzensiz fiiller bir diğer adıyla
10r
gelmesi g verme uzun bir ismi var
Maalesef ki ama biz Şubat'a verdin
kullanabiliriz düzensiz fiiller den
kastım nedir çekimleri düzensiz olan
belli bir kurala uymayan fiiller Peki bu
fiilleri nasıl çekimini yapacağız 6 kişi
zamirine göre ezberlemek zorunda mıyız
Hayır değiliz du Az önce öğrendiğimiz
dusen ve Erciyes yani üçüncü tekil şahıs
larımız olan O şahıs larımız da sadece
ses değişikliğine ol bu mesela a
3A o üzeri iki noktaya dönüyor Ve ben
bunu iki e olarak okuyorum Bir diğer
ismiyle
umlaut Aaa ve uyu a üzerinde iki noktaya
dönüyor Ve ben bunu Oo diye okuyorum oy
oy ya çeviriyorum yine ö diye okuyorum e
gördüğümde ise filmin içinde eğer uzun
telaffuz edilen Neyse iyi ve olarak
değişiyor kısa telaffuz edilen bire ise
sadece iyi olarak değişiyor bunları
örneklerini zaten birazdan göreceğiz
düzenli fiiller imizde ise genel bir
kural var var aşağıda gördüğünüz bilsem
süper olur altı kişi zamirine de göre
belirli bir kuralımız var Nedir bu
kurallar Mesela örnek veriyorum
koymanın fiili gelmek benim sonundaki en
Ekim filmin Master halini belirtiyor
Yani gelmek mek-mak belirtiyor Ben os bu
eki attığımda yerine kişi zamiri M göre
burada gördüğümüz ekleri getiriyorum
mesela
ekomed duş Kont Şimdi farklı renk bir
hemen kalemimi alıyorum
değiştiriyorum kırmızı daha dikkat
çekici olacaktır dukont dediğimde
sonundaki en takısını attım ve sadece
fiilimi kök olarak bıraktım kök olarak
bıraktıktan sonra hemen Burada
gördüğünüz estent en kuralını
uygulayarak altı kişi zamirine göre fiil
imizi çekimle ye biliriz diğer bir
ismiyle hemen şunu da ekliyorum Onur
egilmesi
gevere gelmesi gece yine zor bir
telaffuzu olan kelime ama biz ne yapalım
şut arka veya ben düzenli fiiller
Şubat'a ver ben düzensiz fiiller olarak
kullanalım ve hemen fiil lerimize
geçelim şimdi fiilleri mizin kurallarını
Ya ben sonra bir de bunları fiillerinin
üzerinde görmemiz gerekiyor kamyon fiili
gelmek siparişin fiili konuşmak çıkışın
fiili
düzensiz bir fiil imiz Yani az önce
söylediğim Doğu ikinci tekil ve Erciyes
üçüncü tekil şahıs larımız da harf
düşmesi harf değişmesi belirli bir
değişme oluyor Evet bu Kural Genellikle
bu şekilde ilerliyor ama istisnalar da
tabii ki olabiliyor kombin fiilinden
başlayalım altı kişi zamiri mi gördüm İş
Ben dus enerjiye sovia bezia Siz zi
onlar demiştik ve büyük şehri olan zi
ise ki barzee demiştik
şimdi iş Kome bakın sonundaki Annie
attım ne yapıyorum sadece bire ekliyorum
estent en kuralım a göre Peki hocam O da
ki eve Neyi atmadan sadece ne yapsak
olur mu Tabii ki olur direkt sonundaki
Neyi hemen attım ve sadece Ee bırakarak
filmin çekimleri mdu komz terzi eskom
dvia com'un bakın videoda
gördüğünüz gibi filmin aynı Monster
halini kullanıyorum yani herhangi bir
çekime uğramıyor İyi ya
komsic orman zico'nun yine aynı şekilde
Via da olduğu gibi fiilimi Master
haliyle bırakıyorum şu siparişin fiili
konuşmak düzensiz bir fiil dedik
işbaşı her zaman birinci tekil şahıslar
düzenli gibi ilerler yani sonuna Ben Ee
ne attıktan sonra ya da niye yaptıktan
sonra ne yapıyorum e ekliyorum ya da iyi
bırakıyorum duşu prekast benim burada
Gördüm film şu kışın Normalde bura 11'e
olması gerekiyor ve sonra da ST eklemem
gerekiyor Düzenli bir kurala uyarsan
düzenli fiil kuralına ama gördüğünüz
gibi E gördüm yere filmde e varsa ve
düzensiz bir Fi ise ben hemen E harfini
iyiye çeviriyorum Erciyes pressed bir
yaş kışın yine Master haliyle bıraktım
İyaş pressed zzish peşin zil çıkışın
sadece Dikkat etmem gereken nokta üçüncü
tekil şahıs ve ikinci tek iş Yağız yani
değişime uğrayan tek tek iki kişi zamiri
miz Evet hemen örneklerimiz de devam
edelim
iş Paşa Deutsch Almanca konuşuyorum Evet
gayet Basit bir cümle ama ben kişinin
karşımdaki kişinin Almanca konuştuğunu
nasıl soracağım ya da hangi dili
konuştuğunu nasıl soracağım ve Şifre
şifre stdu çekimlerine dikkat edin dua
Çok
samimi bir kullanım ve ve şiş pradesh
pistu Hangi dili konuşuyorsun Sen peki
Ben kibar olarak soracağım vs şurada
siparişinizin Hangi dili konuşuyorsunuz
bakın cümlenin içinde zili gördüm kibar
Jimmy baş harfin büyük nasıl ayırt
ediyorum baş harfinden ayırt ediyorum
demek ki ben burada Siz diye hitap
ediyorum ve kibar zil kullanıyorum Hangi
dili konuşuyorsunuz iki cümlede iki soru
cümlesinde de ben aynı cevabı veriyorum
İş çıkışı Deutsch özlemi yerleştiriyorum
ardından fiilimi çekiliyorum Özlem'e
göreve ne yapıyorum sonuna da konuştuğum
dili ekliyorum İş çıkışı Dodge İş çıkışı
Süphan iş neydi Şifa nişe İspanyolca bu
peki bilsem süper olur köşesi Özsaray
Avusturya Belgin Belçika lichtenstein
Lüksemburg Deutschland Almanya Burada
gördüğünüz 5 ülkede Almanca konuşuluyor
Avusturya'da Almanca konuşuluyor
Belçika'da Almanca konuşuluyor Listen 3
dyned Lüksemburg ve Deutschland Almanya
da bu da ekstra bir bilgi olsun hemen
pekiştireç pekiştireç bölümümüze geldik
android for Stalin hem birlikte
pekiştireceksiniz hem de bir başkasını
tanıtmayı öğreneceğiz nasıl tanıtıyoruz
diyelim ki yanımızda bir arkadaşımız var
ve onun yanında da onun arkadaşı var ben
arkadaşa tanımıyorum nasıl sorarım veya
istas bu kim Sen bana tanıtır mısın veya
esasder Sistit hemen bakıyorum forname
isim ismi yok almış tanıtıyorum derse
styo Han sadece ismini de söyleyebilirim
ya da Nah name soyisim styn ardından su
ismini de söyleyebilirim ders arrest yok
Einstein Z EST
yâre al
kalıbımız iis yani alt dediğimde bu
boşluğa bir sayı gelmeli yaşı gelmeli
alta yaşlı Öf
veziri İst
Wolf Yare Alo o 12 yaşında her kum
memleket ya da köken Şifa niye nereden
geliyormuş İspanya'dan geliyormuş
zikmund Ağustos
panyan o İspanya'dan geliyor ya da
kısaca ois da diyebiliriz bu North
ikamet yeri oturduğumuz yer nerede
oturuyormuş İspanya'dan geliyormuş ama
İstanbul'da oturuyormuş zi volt
İstanbul Peki Nasyonal it it Milliyet
kökeni neresi İspanya'dan geldiğine göre
İspanyol dememiz lazım ama dikkat
etmemiz gereken nokta Neydi sonundaki
iki harf Şifa niye rinzi rest Sipan
yerin o
İspanyol We Want in İstanbul tanbul da
oturuyor ve son olarak hangi dili
konuşuyor şu rakı dinlemektir Süphan iş
on Turkish
o
zid dediğimde benim burada zaten dilerim
var falan eş İspanyolca
ve
ve Turkish Türkçe Peki benim burada
eksik olan baş harfini eklediğim film ne
paylaşın fiiline yapıyordum 3. tekil
şahısa göre
düzensiz olduğu içine yerine i harfi
getiriyordum veziri pressed süphani
şunun Turkish o zaman ödülü sorumuzu
hemen geçelim bu her comandi BTS BTS
nereli vites Nereden geliyor bu sorunun
cevabını yorumlara bekliyorum yorumlarda
Hatta takip edeceğim bir sonraki
dersimizde görüşmek üzere hoşçakalın o
[Müzik]
abone ol